a court in myanmar has convicted ousted
leader ang sanshu chi on three criminal
charges she's been sentenced to four
years in jail tsuchi was on trial for
illegally possessing walkie-talkies and
for breaking coronavirus rules tony
cheng has more from bangkok
we've just heard from her lawyers that
she was found guilty
on all three charges she was facing one
was for import ex for violating import
export regulations the second was for
violating communications laws and the
third was for breaking covert
regulations against myanmar's natural
disasters management law for the import
export infringement she's got two years
for the communications law she's been
sentenced to one year and for the
breaking covert regulations she's got
another two years the first two charges
will be served concurrently so that's
effectively four years in total
we may see as we saw the last time she
was sentenced to four years
a couple of months ago that the military
intervenes and reduces her sentence
which they did last time to two years in
total to be served under house arrest in
nepal the capital of myanmar
but at this stage
this is just adding more years on an
already existing sentence
that will mean she will be at least 80
by the time she's released from
detention
and i think the the message here is very
clear from the military that they are
taking her out of the picture she has
won elections since she's been released
from house arrest
by an absolute landslide in 2019 which
is what prompted the military coup of
february last year and it seems the
military at this stage are very keen to
keep her out of the picture